hallöchen freuen und herzlich willkommen
in part 2 von die als nummer desert
wasteland wir sind immer noch am start
mit skelett man höre stirbt so und hier
ist auch schon wieder ein kopfloser
zombie smash wieder kaputte ja das ist
super das dann hier gerade auf den trip
an kommt jetzt auch explodiert da kommt
auch sofort ins bett ich kann gar nicht
eine vernünftige begrüßung machen weil
hier sofort wieder alles total caravaca
ist ja langsam ist aber dann noch mal
und sonst so alles gut also in dem
ersten parat habe ich ja gesagt wenn ihr
zweiter haben wollt geht mit einem
daumen hoch wenn nicht dann daumen
runter
viele leute haben dann hoch gegeben
einige wollen es natürlich immer nicht
weiter haben sind dann entweder die
leute die sagen ja kommen
gefällt mir nicht so weit weg oder halt
einfach älter aber ist auch egal
jedenfalls hat die mehrheit dafür
gestimmt dass nichts weiter machen soll
und deswegen dachte ich mir hey komm
dann macht es halt weiter an und wir
sind immer noch hier mitten in der nacht
wenn man noch immer hoffnung dass der
baum wächst ich werde jetzt einfach noch
mal ein bisschen ducati in posen
da es irgendwo bestimmte meiner dinge
hundertprozentig in meiner dinges
das ein bisschen irritierend dass die
keinen kopf haben witzig auf jeden fall
ich weiß nicht ob das ein fehler von
expekt oder irgendwie von mir oder so
keine ahnung also ich werde auf jeden
fall verbessern texture pack kam auch
viele fragen auf wer sich noch
vorstellen
werdet ihr dann erfahren verrottete
fleisch so bist du was ich mache das
jetzt auch einfach mal zu den hier
brauche ich auch noch mal welchen für
werkzeug und es wird schwerer tag wenn
wir ein bisschen rumlaufen und ein
bisschen die wüste erkunden also bisher
muss ich echt sagen diese map finde ich
genial erinnert mich ein bisschen so
habe ja schon gesagt erinnert mich ein
bisschen an sky block in der wüste sage
ich mal so viele steine nämlich
eigentlich gerade so viel brauche ich
gar nicht und ich finde genau das ist
eigentlich ganz gut
nein verdammt
der sand ist runter gefallen ein dritter
faktor 8 schwerkraft der wer braucht da
schon dass uns doch alle einfach durch
die luft fliegen
so ist auch ein naja sagen wir es ist
kein schönes haus aber es ist ein haus
so gut ich wollte mir ein schwert machen
genau euch ganze sachen das nicht mal da
wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen rum gekommen
ich eventuell sich irgendwo runde sich
nicht egal so ach so siehts könnte ich
mitnehmen und direkt neben das wasser
hier schon eine brot jüngst machen
direkt daneben sieht man was willst du
denn hier
okay dass alle offen kripo noch zweimal
gut sei nicht ganz gut dass man das
mittlerweile abschätzen kann wie oft man
alt hat er schon wieder in kryta wie oft
man monster töten wie auch bei monster
schlagen muss damit sie tot sind
ein guter jahrgang bord habe ich weiß
halt nie wofür ich das brauche wäre mir
nachher so was von vielen kritisch ich
kann euch versprechen beste oben eine
spinne okay gut und zwar wollte ich hier
die farben dran bauen
ich weiß sehr sicher direkt neben der
lava aber wir haben bisher noch keine
inszenierte hat force und wir haben auch
keine hoch und ich hab gerade ehrlich
gesagt nicht so das interesse
mitzumachen
ist der wat ich mache jetzt einfach aber
ich muss mir eine kommission home machen
einfach weil wir ich möchte das ganze
holz ich werde nochmal das ist für mich
immer so einen schritt wenn ich dieses
ganze häusern verschwenden muss warum
machst du dir eines tonhöhe recht dafür
weniger holz benötige und kommission
habe ich genug knochen könnte
theoretisch zu knochenmehl machen und
den baum wachsen lassen warum sagt denn
dass hier keiner
menschenskinder stimmt ich war die ganze
zeit ablösen und knochenmehl da drin
machen wir voll die sorgen wegen holz
kommt eigentlich immer ausgeben
baumsetzlinge raus ich weiß gar nicht
wenn jetzt einfach mal die kommentare
schreiben will ich mich sehr darüber
freuen
freu mich allgemein immer über
kommentare manchmal fotografiere ich auf
dem posten bei facebook oder auch fragen
oder so nämlich in der faq serie mit
ryan themen bespreche ich auch also
einfach damit ich euch dann noch ein
bisschen mehr integriere sage ich mal so
ich würde sagen wir können eigentlich
direkt danach das schon ein setzling das
sehr schön
wer direkt in pflanzen schön so macht
das doch spaß rabatt da fällt mir auf da
kann ich ja direkt hier immer ein
bisschen ich meine jetzt kann ich mir
das auch erlauben hier ein bisschen ab
zu fällen wenn wir schon sechs wegen
haben oder wird da was ich setze ihn
einfach mal hier hin da wird er nicht
wachsen welche wird erwachsen
schön
auf mein vater kommt auch eine aus bitte
geht's weiter
hallo bitte noch einer
das wäre jetzt noch ein dritter und noch
nen apfel wir haben auf jeden fall kein
mangel mehr da oder holz mangel das kann
ich sagen alter das doch schon richtig
geile gewonnen naja gut holz immer genug
ich würde sagen wir können direkt
rumlaufen dass man apfel fressen da
hinten sieht so aus als werde irgendwie
so eine höhle muss ich mal schauen
das sieht irgendwie überall so aus als
wäre hier irgendwas und wisst ihr was
ich immer direkt ne das ist da oben da
achter oben ist auch erde dass die erste
erde dings bringt das mit auffällt ich
kann ja schon mal ein paar sachen
abhacken von generator haben wir
unendliche wasserquelle noch nicht
sichere wegpunkte am noch nicht ein haus
haben wir fackel haben wir auch alstom
bekamen wir nicht wollen nicht klar wann
haben wir auch nicht mehr gefunden
findet er dann zwei zusätzliche ordner
mit bisher erst ein wo es auch noch
nicht zu reformen nicht mehr lohnen
fahren weizen formen haben wir schon
viel zwar werde nicht sterben kann die
direkt weg machen weil ich meine ich
will ähnlich auffahrt kaufen da ist es
keine regel die ich so wirklich brauche
und dann würde ich sagen was ich machen
wollte war eine schaufel machen und eine
axt weil wir alle so viel holz haben
sollte das eigentlich kein problem
darstellen
moment hatte schaufel und das schaufel
ich muss mal wieder meine ordnung ist
ein bisschen einhalten
ich könnte noch sollte es machen kommt
ich kann ihn nicht verbrennen ich lasse
das jetzt einfach mal so stehen gut wir
können uns eigentlich direkt der kunden
gehen hhs herzlich geräumt jetzt aber
ein bisschen angst weil wir nicht ohne
fackeln umlauf ist das schon ein
bisschen doof und es wird gleich wieder
nacht hey du sprint ist ein ganzes essen
geht weg nein ich habe eine farm
ich glaube hier könnt ihr irgendwo drin
was sein weil das liegt schon so
verdächtig aus oder auch nicht
ich glaube nicht dass hier alles so ja
ich weiß ich habe dir das alles selber
gebaut ich glaube einfach eine wüste
generiert und habe die da noch die
kopiert oder so da unten sieht auch
irgendwie ziemlich komisch außerdem muss
das sein
hier ist das doch schon so eingegraben
ich hab mich jetzt einfach mal runter
also er meinte es gibt keine höhlen
monster
und ich höre ein höhen sound ich würde
sagen wir uns fackeln und der kunden
dass da mal ein wenig kann ja auch sein
dass es irgendwie eins von diesen
niveaus verstecken oder wieder leute die
sind so was von behinderten hier ist ein
eingang man warum sagt er den nie was
haye sag doch mal hier warum sagst du
nie was mir schon was dass das hier
eigentlich was das für das ob seit
jahren
also ich könnte mit diesem text beck wie
schon gesagt noch nicht so sehr aus ich
kann es jetzt eigentlich unterkommen
weiter
okay die kommt von rechts vor gott ach
du heilige hallo hallo up down ist eine
höhle
das ist schon mal sehr schön ja bauten
sind sehr viele monster kipper alles
mögliche der es explodiert der expediert
jeden moment auf und da seht ihr das
hier ja hier ist eine höhle hallo bitte
weg gehen das wäre ich total nett könnt
ihr euch vielleicht erstmal körper holen
oder so das wäre auch richtig cool ruhig
höher skelette wisst ihr was ich
verziehe mich ich gehe hier gleich noch
mal rein
vielleicht wie komme ich denn jetzt hier
hoch hier schön so ich würde sagen wir
100 ist wird er wieder nacht wir holen
uns fackeln und www wir töten wieder
paar monstern macht das ist das war
deutlich interessanter wo war das
überhaupt das war doch da oder wurde
irgendwo war doch dieser hohe turm
deiner nähe war der der ok das war da da
können wir gleich auch noch hoch gehen
dabei so mitten in der nacht habe ich 13
nicht so wirklich bock drauf ich würde
sagen also ich wir müssen uns auf jeden
fall erstmal auf die suche nach der
dingens begeben nach der nach dem
wasserball an der infinite bord source
ist schon echt wichtig wenn man eine
fahne und alles machen will
ich hoffe mal dass gesetzliche
rauskommen nicht dass uns sache
irgendwie monster oder so alles in der
luft sprengen
so gehen wir da so einen baum
ich habe auch schon wieder mein
komplettes dinges verbraucht hier das
essen london
das lag aber rotes fleisch ja cool hier
ist noch ein baum jetzt auch ein baum
nach dem bogen haben wir vom speed her
wo er mit normalen boden für auch schon
wieder intakt so hierzu ein setzling
schön fackeln kann man eigentlich auch
schon mehr machen weil wegen setzling
weil wegen holz verbrennen und so ist
das ananas apfel ok holz verbrennen habe
ich noch habe ich noch habe ich das
richtig ja so was richtig schön dann
haben wir was du das schon wieder
einsetzen dass es mittlerweile läuft
echt hier wo pflanzen ich hab da mal so
ein bisschen bedenken
ach jetzt ja gar nicht mehr die lava
fällt auf dass auf gremmel warum
anordnung können das glas nicht
irgendwie abbauen kann man das nicht mit
einer schere ich glaube wenn man das
irgendwie enchanted oder so eine
spitzhacke oder so dann kann man damit
sachen abbauen und dann kriegt man die
auch also auch bücherregal oder so also
in einem ganzen stück oder auch glas das
finde ich ist eine der geilsten
entscheidungen weil wenn man sich mit
glas verbaut was damals mal so kann nie
wieder abbauen lassen und setzlingen
euch mal ich weiß nicht wächst hier
komme ich nochmal
so alt haberecht trasse viele setzlinge
da hinten ist ein skelett mit ich hab
mal auch immer witzig dass sie sich
direkt um gewinne dann schießen sie ein
wirklich direkt ab auch ohne körper
total bescheuert oder es ist jetzt
irgendwie neue so minecraft snapshot man
sieht keine zombies mehr weil das dann
viel schwieriger ist wenn man auf
schwierigkeitsgrad 1 ist keine ahnung
was sich wieder von mir gebe
er war noch bleibt so wir haben so was
von alter ist auch noch voll viele
setzlinge was fast vorüber damit den
ganzen vorhin am anfang weil sie noch so
ja setzlinge u
gut ich würde sagen wir bauen einfach
überall in die wüste so ein paar bäume
hin
man sieht das ja auch ein bisschen
schöner aus nicht so trist jeweilig eine
farm hinbauen stimmt